oh là les amours ce petit message pour
me dire qu'on se retrouve dimanche 11
décembre pour la première édition de
Kaba baby party un spectacle pour les
enfants de 0 à 3 ans mais aussi pour les
parents alors soyez au rendez-vous au
blond de Vénus le dimanche 11 décembre
alors ce sera dimanche à 15h30 si
j'étais bordelais j'emmènerai des
enfants c'est une initiative formidable
c'est génial pas loin Bordeaux tu peux y
aller ouais c'est pour l'inclusion je
trouve ça extraordinaire des clowns drag
queen je vois pas où est le problème
alors quelques réactionnaires qui
s’émovent franchement il y a pas lieu
d'être Cyril bravo à eux Géraldine
3 ans Gilles donc pas c'est pas des
citoyens c'est pas de même des jeunes
adultes 0 à 3 ans on n'a pas leur faire
des stages sur le mariage pour tous les
droits LGBT l'inclusivité tu vois c'est
il y a un moment donné où 0,3 ans on
n'est pas là-dedans donc si elle avait
peut-être un mais là ils sont tous comme
ça donc c'est pas possible en fait mais
quel est le problème justement 0 3 ans
ça va les sensibiliser elles vont être
choquées la sensibiliser un monde de 0
ou 3 ans dans son dans son parc à jouer
sur ça ou sur son transat en lisant
alors ça voilà ça il faut que tu saches
pardon
l'idée c'est pas c'est pas de leur
renseigner quelque chose tu vois autant
à l'école qu'on vient d'expliquer les
LGBT tout ça je trouve que c'est pas la
place dans une école autant là au
contraire 03 ans tu leur explique rien
tu dois montres c'est juste pour que il
se rendent compte que finalement bah la
différence que un tranche pas un trans
c'est juste que à l'oeil une fois plus
choqué après c'est différent
tu me déçois énormément c'est très grave
ce que tu es en train de dire est-ce que
tu vois étant bah c'est simple l'extrait
qu'on vient de voir collier de chien et
collier de chien mais tu as vu ça où
mais un bébé de 0 à 3 ans tu crois
vraiment que les parents vont les
emmener
la différence
ça fait peur mais tu es un malade
une question c'est quoi ça papa c'est
quoi sa maman pourquoi il est comme ça
c'est pas mal et on a besoin
[Applaudissements]
entre 0 et 3 ans non mais c'est
n'importe quoi on peut on peut on peut
soutenir quelque chose respecter une
cause sans pour autant qu'elle soit
partout tout le temps et avec tout le
monde et à n'importe quel âge vous aurez
quoi vous êtes ta meuf
[Rires]
chéri
de quoi j'adore merci moi aussi ça va
bien le jaune comme ça merci
obsédé par l'homosexualité c'est pas du
tout c'est insupportable oui tu viens le
droit de référence oui tu viens de me
demander si je suis gay arrête un peu
c'est pas ça
il te demande juste si au cas où vous
soyez bloqué dans un ascenseur j'ai
jamais demandé
homophobe on est malade est-ce que tu
m'as entendu parler d'homosexualité oui
la vie de différentes les gens de Rex
moi si j'avais un réaction entre 0 et 3
ans je suis désolé
non j'ai dit que tu étais différent
voilà c'est à dire mais c'est un support
il est magnifique comme ça mais il est
magnifique on peut être magnifique c'est
un look oui c'est un look c'est ça voilà
voilà en parlant de Daniel Moreau
ça y est c'est fait
il y a une différence
j'aimerais bien hein
j'en ai marre parce qu'en plus on on est
presque courageux de dire ça parce que
on est traité d'homophobe j'en ai marre
moi je m'en fous je je garde mes réac de
je sais pas très bien
oui juste tu n'as pas d'enfants je crois
pas honnêtement c'est même pas une
question de militantisme LGBT un enfant
de 0 à 3 ans il va avoir des gens
différents il risque d'avoir simplement
peur non sans se poser mais comment ça
non non pas beaucoup plus qu'avec des
clowns
de leur flanquer la trouille sans
rentrer dans un discours t'es homophobie
là où c'est ça c'est basiquement juste
pour les préserver jeans enfin c'est
très grave ce qu'il dit
non mais moi déjà tu as un avantage tu
as compris ce qu'il a dit
c'est très grave parce que en fait ils
sont en train de nier le droit à la
différence exactement d'uniformiser la
société et si on sensibilise pas les
enfants si on leur montre pas des gens
tel qu'ils sont ça va faire des
réactionnaires qui après vont rejeter
ma fille elle était petite on est allé à
une réunion de Drag Queen et je lui ai
montré elle était très bien
et franchement c'est formidable Cyril il
faut habituer les enfants à ça et la
raison ça le nombre de réactionnaires
sur ce plateau m'intrigue fortement
considérablement bravo Mathieu alors
bravo bravo
traité de réalité
et j'en suis
réactionnaire je trouve pas que ce soit
très positif et un moment donné moi pour
moi les parents qui vont emmener voir
leurs enfants pour voir ce genre de
spectacle pour moi je suis désolé je le
dis ça va en faire des des enfants
perturbés parce que c'est pas à l'orage
parce que c'est pas on les force pas à
aller voir quelque chose comme ça avec
des gens qui ont des colliers de chats
des pics des yeux noirs des gens qui
pleurent avec du mascara noir qui coule
enfin pas de 0 à 3 ans je veux dire faut
être irresponsable pour sortir
et puis arrêtez de comparer l'écran ça
Halloween ou à des clowns enfin
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette histoire
contre Mathieu Delormeau
mais c'est vrai match ça va oui je crois
que c'est très intéressant
et qu'il faut continuer merci de me
donner la parole Jean-Marie Jean-Marie
moi je m'en branle un petit peu hein
allez les enfants de 3 ans et il faut
pas chercher dans la tête des enfants de
3 ans qu'ils vont ou mal ou bien le
prendre il voit des gens déguisés je
pense que c'est tout et que c'est pas
mal qu'il voit des gens de toutes les
couleurs ça les amuse plutôt que de
regarder un voyageur de commerce ou un
représentant d'une banque ou un truc
comme ça bonjour Marie-Pierre
ce qui est vrai c'est que c'est nous qui
projetons énormément de choses sur ces
enfants et effectivement alors moi je
pense qu'une une fête pour enfant doit
rester une fête pour enfants mais malgré
tout je pense que chacun ici projette
une grille de lecture sur cette fête qui
a une grille d'adulte exactement tu as
raison c'est vous qui politisez des
choses les enfants ils voient pas ça
différence
pose des questions donc comment tu vas
lui raconter ça comment tu vas lui dire
avec tes mots de papa mais tu restes
comme ça
que dans la rue moi des gens différents
ça peut être quelqu'un de couleur ça
peut être un trop ce que tu veux
tu réponds avec voilà tu dis voilà et
puis on est tous
par la cheminée
comment la rue ça s'appelle un père Noël
il existe la rue il existe la télé il y
a beaucoup de choses qu'on peut
expliquer aux enfants ce que c'est un
transexuel pourquoi tu as besoin de les
amener voir un peu dans la rue leur
expliquer mais pas dans les amener voir
quelque chose
papa pourquoi il y a différentes
couleurs papa c'est pas 0,3 ans merci on
va voir ce qu'on pensait téléspectateurs
parce que c'est vrai que ah oui bah
voilà bonne idée non de toute façon ils
sont dès que j'y vais quelque chose